vamos con el problema número 17 dice
cuál de las siguientes opciones describe
de la mejor manera los triángulos que se
muestran aquí tenemos los dos triángulos
y las opciones tienen que ver con que
los triángulos sean semejantes o
congruentes bueno vamos a pensarlo a ver
aquí tenemos este triángulo que tiene un
ángulo de 90 grados de 90 grados y otro
de 60 grados y en un triángulo la suma
de las medidas de los tres ángulos debe
ser 180 grados 90 y 60 son 150 así que
aquí aquí tiene que medir 30 grados va
vamos a hacer lo mismo de este lado este
es de 90 grados 90 30 y 120 y 120 para
180 es 60 grados entonces este de acá es
60 grados
entonces observa resulta que los dos
triángulos tienen exactamente los mismos
ángulos 30 60 90 30 60 90 entonces
podemos empezar diciendo que son
semejantes
semejantes semejantes o sea a sus lados
guardan la misma proporción
vamos a intentar ver cuál es esta
proporción si esa proporción es 1
entonces también son congruentes
entonces aquí tenemos un 8 que es la
medida de este lado y este lado de acá
también mide 8 entonces pues son
triángulos congruentes verdad porque la
razón de este lado a este lado es 1
entonces los triángulos son semejantes
en razón uno a uno y por lo tanto cada
uno de sus lados correspondientes mide
lo mismo este de acá me diría lo mismo
que acá ya estoy acá me diría lo mismo
que estoy acá y por lo tanto también son
congruentes con un grupo entes muy bien
entonces
ambos son semejantes y congruentes si
esta es la opción que queremos muy bien
salen entonces eso resuelve el problema
17 vamos con el 18 problema 18 cuál de
los siguientes enunciados debe ser
cierto si el triángulo g h
es semejante esta rayita quiere decir
semejante o sea cuando está así dejar un
color más brillante cuando está así
quiere decir semejante semejante y
cuando tiene la igualdad quiere decir
congruente congruente congruente muy
bien entonces cuál de los siguientes
enunciados debe ser cierto si el
triángulo gh es semejante al j k l pues
vamos a ver los enunciados a los dos
triángulos deben ser escaleno no claro
que no verdad hay triángulos que son
semejantes entre sí y que no son
escaleno por ejemplo dos triángulos
equiláteros pues no son escale nos y son
semejantes entonces la opción a la
opción a no es la correcta
b los dos triángulos tienen exactamente
un ángulo agudo no eso es falso otra vez
el ejemplo de los dos x lateros de los
dos x lateros pues nos muestra que dos
triángulos semejantes pueden tener más
de un ángulo agudo de hecho o sea yo
creo que no existen triángulos con solo
un ángulo agudo porque tenían que tener
dos rectos o dos obtusos o un reto y un
obtuso y creo que no se puede pero bueno
la opción de tampoco es correcta se hace
al menos uno de los lados de los dos
triángulos deben ser paralelos o sea por
ejemplo que éste sea paralelo a éste
pues no no importa o sea no nos importa
o sea como es la posición de los
triángulos solo nos importa que tengan
la misma forma este triángulo pudiera
estar así más o menos así y entonces no
habría lados paralelos pero seguirían
siendo semejantes entonces no lo hace
tampoco es correcta
entonces debe ser la de pero vamos a
asegurarnos que si de los lados
correspondientes de los triángulos
guardan la misma proporción a pues y eso
es exactamente la definición de que dos
triángulos sean semejantes va entonces
pues básicamente nos están preguntando
si no sabemos la definición de semejanza
bueno problema número 19 problema número
19 en la siguiente figura el segmento ac
es congruente al df entonces este de acá
mide lo mismo que éste de acá y además
el ángulo en la es congruente al ángulo
en d el ángulo en
es congruente al ángulo en de muy bien
vamos a ver que nos preguntan qué
información adicional sería suficiente
para mostrar que el triángulo abc es
congruente al triángulo de efe este de
acá queremos que sea congruente al de
abajo a este de acá
y justo en ese orden verdad con db con s
con efe muy bien bueno pues ya tenemos
que este lado es congruente a este que
este ángulo es congruente a éste
entonces podemos podemos intentar
completar la congruencia de dos formas
una opción una opción sería que este
ángulo de aquí fuera congruente a este
ángulo de acá entonces pudiéramos
utilizar el criterio ángulo lado ángulo
el criterio de congruencia ángulo lado
ángulo y otra opción otra opción sería
que este segmento me diera lo mismo que
este segmento de acá y entonces
pudiéramos utilizar el criterio de
congruencia lado ángulo lado lado ángulo
lado vamos a ver si alguna de estas
opciones está por acá entonces a que el
segmento ave ave sea congruente al del
talde si esta es una de las opciones
verdad
es una de las opciones si tuviéramos a
entonces pudiéramos decir son
congruentes son congruentes por por el
criterio lado ángulo lado va pero para
no dejar vamos a ver qué dicen las otras
b a b es congruente a veces a b es
congruente abc pues eso no debería
funcionar o sea sólo dice que estés
isósceles pero no relaciona los dos
triángulos se ve ce es congruente
efe bc es congruente a efe aquí hay que
tener cuidado porque tendríamos este
lado este lado y este ángulo de acá vale
sea este lado este lado y este ángulo de
acá pero el ángulo no es el ángulo entre
lados correspondientes entonces por ahí
antes ya platicamos que eso no
necesariamente nos da chance de concluir
que sean congruentes bueno lo vimos con
semejanza pero el argumento es muy
similar aquí en esta figura pues si nos
va a permitir concluirlo porque veces no
es el lado más chico pero si veces fuera
el más chico entonces se pudiera mover
hacia dos lados y entonces tendríamos
problemas pero bueno el chiste es que
ese tampoco función
y finalmente de bs es congruente a de bs
congruente a d
no pues esos ni siquiera son lados
correspondientes con respecto a lo que
ya tenemos entonces esto tampoco tampoco
funciona como puedes ver estas preguntas
tienen muchísimo que ver con
definiciones y no me están gustando
tanto las preguntas de este otro examen
de eeuu el st son un poco más padres por
qué pues porque te ayudan a desarrollar
un poco más la intuición de los
triángulos o sea en realidad de estas
preguntas del examen de california
parecen ser muy teóricas tienen muchas
definiciones semejanzas congruencias
criterios esa s l a l más bien a ella
entonces está como que todo muy muy
teórico hasta ahorita no me está
gustando prefiero el ls ate el lg ate
como que ayuda a dar un poco más de
intuición y ayuda para el futuro en una
carrera matemática como que entiendes un
poco mejor las matemáticas y así pero ya
me estoy quejando demasiado pero es
importante eso es importante decirte que
y no nos van a importar en el futuro las
definiciones es muy probable que esté
simbólico de congruentes jamás lo
vuelvas a ver en tu carrera matemática
incluso aunque estudies un doctorado
pero las ideas detrás las cosas
matemáticas entender cómo son las
implicaciones eso sí que va a ayudar en
tu carrera matemática y bueno como
puedes ver pues yo yo estoy mucho más
feliz con el st que con este examen de
california pero bueno ni modo vamos a
tener que seguir haciendo esto y vamos a
seguir aprendiendo notación y teoremas
entonces problema número 20 problema
número 20 dado que el segmento a b y c
de ave y cede se intersectan en el punto
en este punto de acá y el ángulo 1 es
congruente al ángulo 2 el ángulo 1 es
congruente al ángulo 2 lo voy a marcar
en color azul y este de acá es
congruente a este de acá
qué teorema o postulado se puede usar
para probar que el triángulo
es semejante al triángulo bs bs
con bs bueno vamos a pensar algunas
cosas observa que este ángulo es igual a
este y estos todos parecen muchísimo dos
ángulos alternos internos sólo hay que
hay que ver de qué entonces según yo si
pensamos hace de como una transversal
como una transversal de ade y de i d c b
podemos ver que justo estos ángulos son
ángulos alternos internos con esta
transversal y por lo tanto a de va a ser
paralelo acb si los ángulos alternos
internos son iguales entonces y los
segmentos o las líneas correspondientes
las líneas que son atravesadas son son
paralelas vale entonces este es paralelo
a este de acá
pero creo que ese paralelismo no nos
ayuda mucho verdad en realidad queremos
probar la semejanza de este triángulo de
este triángulo con este triángulo de acá
y ya tenemos que este ángulo es igual a
este y además aquí nos pone en el ángulo
3 y el 4 muy sugerentemente así que a lo
mejor convenga trabajar con ellos pues
es justo esto de que son ángulos
opuestos por el vértice verdad el ángulo
3 es congruente al ángulo 4 porque ambos
son opuestos al vértice e y por lo tanto
pues son congruentes entonces qué sucede
con el triángulo ade
y el bc pues que ya tienen dos ángulos
congruentes el 1 es congruente al 2 y el
13 es congruente al 4 entonces estos dos
triángulos deben ser semejantes porque
el tercer ángulo como la suma de los
ángulos internos del triángulo debe ser
180 y ya tienen estos dos iguales pues
entonces el tercer ángulo también debe
ser congruente entonces estos ángulos
que estoy pintando en verde también son
congruentes entre sí y entonces en
realidad qué criterio usamos pues el
criterio ángulo ángulo verdad tan sólo
con tener dos ángulos iguales en dos
triángulos entonces el tercero también
debe ser igual y por lo tanto son
triángulos semejantes vamos a ver si eso
está por aquí claro aquí esta opción a
criterio ángulo ángulo de semejanza de
semejanza creo que dice congruentes pero
más bien son semejantes muy bien
entonces vamos a dejarle hasta aquí ya
no me queda tiempo para otro problema
sobre todo porque me empecé a quejar
mucho pero bueno está bien vamos a
seguir con estos problemas igual y
encontramos algo rescatable del 21 en
adelante